pfizer's covid vaccine is on everyone's
mind today as it is now fully approved
by the fda and as it is now has the same
level of regulations as other vaccines
companies universities and local
governments are expected in some cases
to make the shop mandatory christian
casares joining us in studio with more
on what this approval means well brian
the fda approval could reverse a
nationwide slowdown in the pace of first
doses now it comes nine months after
emergency use authorization was given
pfizer's covet 19 vaccine is the first
to be fully approved by the federal
regulators it will be marketed under the
name community fda officials hope the
approval lifts public confidence in the
vaccine among the unvaccinated the
public can be confident that this
vaccine meets the fda's gold standards
for safety effectiveness and
manufacturing quality that we require
for an approved product president biden
had a message for americans who vowed to
wait for full approval before getting
inoculated the moment you've been
waiting for us here it's time for you to
go get your vaccination and get it today
following approval the pentagon
announced it will require members of the
military to get the vaccine and new york
city's public school teachers and
staffers must do so as well and as more
children head back into the classroom a
cbs news poll finds while the majority
of parents support a mask requirement
they are split over a vaccine
requirement it found 48 percent of
parents think schools should require a
vaccine while 52 percent believe schools
should not
applied to the fda for full approval of
its vaccine johnson johnson said it
hopes to do so later this year